-It is January.
It's freezing outside
and everyone has the blahs.
That includes
my monologue writers.
[ Laughter and awws ]
No, it's okay.
It's okay.
They're human,
just like the rest of us.
It may seem hard to believe,
but they write hundreds of jokes
every day,
just to get the 10 or 12 we use
in the monologue.
And, let's face it,
a lot of those jokes,
you know, they're not great
and, honestly, sometimes I think
they just throw in
some real stinkers
to fill up the page
and meet the assignment.
[ Laughter ]
But just because it's January
and the sun goes down at 5:00 pm
doesn't mean we can
tolerate laziness,
which means it's time
for a "Surprise Inspection."
[ Trumpet blows reveille ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
It's a very long intro.
[ Laughter ]
So here's how this works.
These are real jokes,
really submitted by my writers,
that are unusable for the show.
Some are dumb,
some are patently offensive,
and some just don't make sense.
Most importantly, the writers
don't know we're doing this
[ Audience ohs ]
and, because a lot of them
don't watch the show,
they'll never know
we're doing this.
[ Laughter ]
So let's get to it.
The European bank Santander
took back more than $170 million
that they had
accidentally deposited
into customers' bank accounts
on Christmas Day,
due to a "scheduling issue,"
and it's incidents like this
that make kids stop believing
in Santander.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
That was written by Ian.
[ Laughter ]
And it somehow went back in time
and ruined Christmas for me.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida couple last month
discovered a colony
of 80,000 bees
hidden behind their shower wall.
Said, the wife,
"Honey!"
[ Laughter and ohs ]
[ Applause ]
That was also written by Ian.
[ Laughter ]
Which I think qualifies him
as a serial killer.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
According to a new study,
playing a recording
of people's names while sleeping
can improve name recall
the next day.
"Worked for me,"
said Lou Bega.
[ Laughter ]
[ Applause ]
So, that one requires you
to remember
the 1999 song...
[ Laughter ]
..."Mambo No. 5" and,
even then, not a great joke.
[ Laughter ]
I'd say that would've gone
maybe 2% better in 1999.
[ Laughter ]
Uh...
Wait, that was
"A little bit of...
"A little bit of Monica," right?
"A little bit," yeah.
That was okay.
In 1999, you were allowed
to have several girlfriends.
[ Laughter ]
As long as only a little bit
of them were in your life.
[ Laughter ]
So like Erica would say like,
"Are you seeing someone
named Monica?"
And you were like,
"A little bit."
[ Laughter ]
It was a different time,
you guys.
More than 800 parakeets
were recently surrendered
to a Michigan animal shelter.
It's been a rough month
for excessive tweeters.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
♪ A little bit of Marjorie ♪
[ Laughter ]
A court -- 1999!
Most popular show -- "Friends."
Unlike today, where I think
it's still "Friends."
[ Laughter ]
According to the latest numbers,
the U.S. is averaging more
than 386,000 new cases
of the coronavirus each day,
so call me Ellen DeGeneres,
because this studio audience
is all going home
with something!
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
[ Laughter and ohs ]
Are you are you just clapping
because you don't know
what else to do?
[ Laughter ]
Is that how much you like
free things,
even if it's a virus?
You're like, "Aah!"
[ Cheering ]
[ Claps ]
Rapper Cardi B tweeted yesterday
that she wanted to get
her son's name tattooed
on her face.
Fortunately, her son's name is
Cheek.
[ Laughter ]
Karen Chee wrote that joke.
Karen is just an adorable,
adorable person.
There she is.
[ Laughter and awws ]
And, yet, if you saw her now,
do remember to flip her off.
[ Laughter ]
Let's win it.
You know what?
I'm going to win you guys back
with an uplifting one.
Because that cheek joke was --
Let's be honest.
We need to do a little work
to win you guys back.
Today was actor Mel Gibson's
66th birthday.
Unfortunately,
when he blew out the candles,
there were still some Jews.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
So sad.
He had a bad birthday.
[ Laughter ]
We can't do that.
You could never do that on TV.
[ Laughter ]
Imagine what would happen if I
said that joke on television.
[ Laughter ]
People were at home watching TV.
Thank God we caught it
in this "Surprise Inspection."
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
17% of Americans said
that they would like
to receive sexual favors
as a gift for Valentine's Day.
Said the surveyor,
Okay, but I just did
the last house,
so I'm going to need like
20 minutes to get going again."
[ Laughter ]
Former first lady Michelle Obama
turned 58 today.
And, by the way,
these aren't all written today.
I'm trying to stop
what just happened.
[ Laughter ]
Not her birthday today.
I would hate for you to clap
for that
after you clapped
about the free virus.
[ Laughter, cheering,
and applause ]
Let's take it back.
Let's get this set up
because this one's real nice.
Let's see who wrote it.
Go before.
Oh, Scollins wrote this.
If you watch our show, you know
anything about Scollins,
you know he's a bad guy.
[ Laughter ]
Former First Lady Michelle Obama
turned 58 today
and, if you're wondering
what her secret is --
[ Whispering ]
Barack was born in Kenya.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
"Scream" premiered this weekend
at the box office
and, if you want
to know who dies --
the unvaccinated audience.
[ Laughter and ohs ]
This whole thing was some pri--
[ Laughter ]
This has been
"Surprise Inspection."
[ Trumpet blows reveille ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪